hello everyone and welcome to this video
on the hackers roadmap at the simply
land YouTube channel as vast as the
field of cyber security is there is
often an overflow of information about
it at the same time for people who wish
to know more about how to venture into
the cyber security or ethical hacking
space it is very important for them to
know what's the career progression what
are the skills needed and how a person
with no or bare minimum knowledge can
take the first step in this amazing
career well this video is for all those
individuals who wish to pursue a career
in the field of cyber security and
ethical hacking whether you are an entry
level professional a college graduate or
an experienced professional looking to
understand how a career in the field of
cyber security progresses and what
additional skills and responsibilities
who you need as you grow in the field
then you are at the right place so let's
get started with our topic the hackers
roadmap and before we begin if you are
someone who is interested in building a
career in cyber security by graduating
from the best universities or a
professional who elicits to switch
careers with cyber security while
learning from the experts then
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering the
course link is mentioned in the
description box that will navigate you
to the course page where you can find a
complete overview of the program being
offered and if these are the types of
videos you would like to watch then hit
the Subscribe button like and press on
the Bell icon to never miss on further
content so stay tuned with us until the
end of this video and don't forget to
register your opinion in the comment
section below and now we will start with
what is ethical hacking and how is it
different from hacking
so in the world of cyber security
hacking can be broadly characterized
into two types ethical hacking and
unethical hacking
ethical hacking involves using the same
tools and techniques as malicious
hackers to identify and fix security
vulnerabilities before they can be
exploited and these experts known as
Whitehead hackers work with a focus on
security rather own theft
and on the other hand we have unethical
hacking that refers to unauthorized
access to digital devices or networks
with malicious intent performed by black
attackers
and additionally there are gray
attackers who possess knowledge in
offensive and defensive computer use
sometimes working as Security
Consultants during the day and engaging
in black hat activities at night it is
important to understand these
distinctions to protect against cyber
threats effectively now we'll see the
objective or roles of an ethical hacker
ethical hackers also known as white
hijackers use their skills and expertise
to identify vulnerabilities in system
and network before malicious hackers can
exploit them their primary objective is
to simulate real-world attacks and help
organization strengthen their security
measures the role of an ethical hacker
involves several key phases and will see
those roles and key phases
so they are responsible for
reconnaissance scanning cane and
maintain access clear their tracks
document their findings and compile
detailed reports
so firstly they conduct thorough
recurrence gathering information about
the target system or organization this
includes understanding the
organization's structure Network
infrastructure and potential weak points
and through scanning they identify the
easiest and quickest methods to gain
access to the network and gather further
information
and once access has gained ethical
hackers maintain it allowing them to
exercise their Privileges and control
the connected systems this step helps
them identify any potential security
flows and weaknesses within the network
they also work to clear their tracks
covering their footsteps to evade
detection and ensuring the security
Personnel cannot Trace their activities
and throughout the entire process
ethical hackers document their findings
compile detailed reports on the
vulnerabilities discovered and provide
recommendations to address and mitigate
the identified security issues their
vulnerability goal is to help
organization strengthen their defenses
prevent data breaches and protect
sensitive information from falling into
the wrong hands ethical hacking is a
crucial aspect of cyber security as it
allows organizations to stay one step
ahead of cyber threats by leveraging the
skills of ethical hackers businesses can
proactively identify and address
vulnerabilities ensuring the overall
security and integrity of their digital
infrastructure so now we'll see the
skills that needed to be an ethical
hacker
so now we will see the skills so the
first skill is knowledge of computer
networks then it's the programming
languages then the knowledge of web
applications databases ethical hacking
tools and knowledge of common attack
vectors and techniques then what
certificates that are required for an
ethereal hacker now we'll start with
knowledge of computer networks
understanding computer networks is
fundamental for ethical hackers this
includes Concepts such as IP addressing
Network protocols example TCP IP routing
switching and firewalls a strong grasp
of how networks function will enable you
to identify vulnerabilities and
potential entry points the next is
programming languages
Proficiency in programming languages is
essential for Effective ethical hacking
languages like python Java C plus plus
and scripting languages such as Pearl or
Ruby are widely used in this field
programming skills enable you to write
custom scripts and tools automate tasks
and expert vulnerabilities and the next
we have is web applications in today's
digital landscape web applications are
often the target of attacks therefore a
solid understanding of web application
architecture protocols example HTTP and
security mechanisms example SSL TLS is
crucial knowledge of web programming
languages like HTML CSS JavaScript and
Frameworks like PHP or asp.net is also
beneficial then we have databases so
databases store and manage sensitive
data making them attractive targets for
hackers familiarize yourself with
database Management systems dbms such as
MySQL Oracle or Microsoft SQL Server
learn about database security including
access control encryption and
vulnerability assessment then we should
focus on the skill to have a knowledge
on ethical hacking tools so to perform
ethical hacking task efficiently you
should be familiar with various hacking
tools these include Network scanners
example and map vulnerability scanners
example nessus password crackers Joan
the riper packet snipers Wireshark and
exploration Frameworks Metasploit
mastering these tools will enhance your
Effectiveness as an ethical hacker then
you should have knowledge of common
attack vectors and techniques that is
understanding common attack vectors and
techniques is vital for an ethical
hacker this includes knowledge of
different types of malware social
engineering Network attacks that is DDOS
and web application vulnerabilities
example cross site scripting staying up
to date with the latest threads and
attack methodologies is crucial for
Effective difference
the next is certificates so obtaining
relevant certifications demonstrates
your expertise and commitment to the
field certificates like certified
ethical hacker CH offensive security
certificate professional oscp or CompTIA
Security Plus are highly regarded within
the industry they validate your skills
and can boost your credibility when
seeking ethical hacking opportunities
the CH certification is a multiple
choice exam that evaluates your
understanding of the penetration testing
structure and the tools that are
utilized inside it it gives job Seekers
the information security field a head
start by ensuring that the certificate
holder understands the fundamentals such
as information gathering attacking
computers or servers Wireless attacks
and social engineering so the objective
CHS inform the public that
credentialized individuals meet or
exceed the minimum standards second
establish and govern minimum standards
of credit entity
third professional information security
specialist in ethical hacking so now
we'll have an exam review so the exam
name is EC Council certified ethical
hacker and the exam duration is 240
minutes and you will get questions that
is 125 questions you will get in the
exam and it is a multiple choice
question exam and the passing score you
need is 70 percent
and to register for the exam you should
go to Pearson view or ECC Exam Center
and eligibility criteria for CHS there
are two ways to satisfy the eligibility
criteria that is attend official CH
training and this can be in any format
example instructor-led training
computer-based training or live online
training as long as the program is
approved by EC Council an attempt
without official training in order to be
considered for the EC council
certification exam without attending
official training you must have two or
more years of documented information
security experience remit a
non-refundable eligibility application
fee of hundred dollars submit completed
CH exam eligibility form including
verification from an employer upon
approval EC Council will email your
voucher number to register for the CH
exam so this was all about the CH exam
and now we will move to the steps to
become ethical hacker so ethical hacking
is an exciting and rapidly growing field
that requires a combination of technical
skills knowledge and a strong sense of
Ethics by following these steps you can
begin your journey towards becoming an
ethical hacker and contribute to
enhancing cyber security so step one
that is knowledge of computer systems
and networks Step 2 you should have
Proficiency in programming languages
step 3 networking and security Concepts
you should have a knowledge of it third
knowledge of web application and
database fifth understanding of
operating systems step 6 family IDT with
ethical hacking tools step 7 problem
solving and analytical thinking step 8
knowledge of common attack vectors and
techniques step 9 certifications so now
we will elaborate all the steps one by
one so we'll start with knowledge of
computer systems and networks so to
become an ethical hacker it is crucial
to have a deep understanding of computer
systems and networks this involves
familiarizing yourself with the inner
workings of computer system Network
protocols operating systems and how
different components interact within a
network environment by gaining this
knowledge you will be better equipped to
identify vulnerabilities and assess
potential security risk and the next is
Proficiency in programming languages so
programming languages are an essential
tool for ethical hackers by gaining
Proficiency in programming languages
such as python C plus plus Java
JavaScript SQL perm and Ruby you will be
able to develop your own scripts
automate tasks and create exploit codes
these programming languages provide the
foundation for writing secure and
efficient code as well as manipulating
and analyzing data the next step is
networking and security Concepts to
effectively assess and secure networks
it is important to have a solid
understanding of networking and security
concept this includes familiarizing
yourself with topics such as Network
protocols network security principles
encryption techniques and firewall
configurations understanding how data is
transmitted secured and protected in a
network environment will enable you to
identify potential vulnerabilities and
Implement appropriate security measures
step 4 knowledge of web application and
database knowledge so in today's
interconnected World web applications
and databases are common targets for
hackers therefore it is crucial to
develop a strong understanding of web
application architectures web protocols
and database systems pay special
attention to Common management abilities
specific to web applications such as SQL
injection close site scripting xss and
close site request forgery csrf by
gaining expertise in these areas you
will be able to effectively assess the
security of web applications and
databases and provide appropriate
recommendations for securing them and
the next step is understanding of
operating systems so operating systems
form the backbone of computer systems
and are often targeted by hackers it is
important to gain a comprehensive
understanding of different operating
systems such as Windows Linux or Mac OS
this includes understanding system
configurations file permissions user
management and security mechanism
specific to each operating system this
knowledge will enable you to identify
vulnerabilities apply patches and secure
operating systems effectively step 6
familiarity with ethical hacking tools
ethical hackers rely on a variety of
tools to assess and secure systems and
networks familiarize yourself with
popular ethical hacking tools such as
mad sproutlip Wireshark and map burp
suit Kali Linux canvas SQL ninja and
Wapiti these tools provide
functionalities for vulnerability
scanning Network sniffing explore
development and penetration testing
understanding how to use these tools
effectively will enhance your
capabilities as an ethical hacker now
we'll see the step 7 that is problem
solving and analytical thinking so being
an ethical hacker requires strong
problem solving skills and the ability
to think analytically you will often
encounter complex systems and face
intricate security challenges developing
your problem solving abilities and
analytical thinking will help you
approach these challenges systematically
identify vulnerabilities and devise
effective strategies to mitigate risk it
is essential to stay updated with the
latest security Trends and Technologies
to enhance your problem solving skills
and the step it is knowledge of common
attack vectors and techniques so to
Define against potential threats you
must familiarize yourself with common
hacking techniques and attack vectors
used by malicious hackers this includes
social engineering phishing attacks
password cracking Network waste attacks
and more understanding how these attacks
work and the methodologies used will
enable value to proactively identify and
prevent potential security breaches and
now the step 9 that is certifications
while certifications are not mandatories
to start a career in ethical hacking
they can provide a structured learning
path and validate your skills and
knowledge consider pursuing
certification such as certified ethical
hacker CH offensive security certified
professional oscp certified information
system security professional cissp
certified penetration Testing Engineer
CPT and certified security analyst ecsa
these certifications demonstrate your
expertise and dedication to the field
enhancing your credibility as an ethical
hacker now we will see the job roles in
ethical hacking field so starting with
like there are several job roles in
ethical hacking such as here's an
elaboration on each job role in ethical
hacking and we'll see some of the major
ethical hacker job roles so starting
with ethical hacker so an ethical hacker
is a skilled professional who legally
attempts to penetrate computer system
and networks to identify vulnerabilities
and weaknesses they use their knowledge
to strengthen the security
infrastructure and protect against cyber
threats and the next is network security
engineer network security Engineers
specialize in securing and maintaining
computer networks within an organization
they Implement and manage security
measures such as firewalls intuition
detection systems and virtual private
networks that is vpns to protect
sensitive data then we have cyber
security analyst so cyber security
analyst Monitor and analyze systems for
potential security breaches or incidents
they investigate threats develop
security protocols and Implement
measures to protect against attacks the
next is penetration tester penetration
testers also known as ethical hackers
simulate real world attacks to identify
vulnerabilities in computer systems
networks and applications they conduct
thorough assessments and provide
recommendations for improving security
the next is information security manager
information security managers are
responsible for overseeing and
organization's overall security strategy
and ensuring the protection of sensitive
data they develop and Implement security
policies many security teams and handle
incident response and the next is cyber
security engineer so cyber security
Engineers design and Implement security
systems including firewalls encryption
protocols and intrusion detection
systems do you also conduct risk
assessments and perform security audits
to maintain a security environment and
the next is security consultant Security
Consultants provide expert advice and
guidance on security strategies and
solutions the assess vulnerabilities
develop security plans and assist
organizations in improving their overall
security posture in the United States
these requirements are very high and
this was all for this tutorial and now
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers and this was
all for this tutorial hope you guys
found it informative and helpful let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers hi I'm Philip I am 61
years old and last year IOP skill was
simply postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
I.T sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors I worked
with many companies before the security
analysts and the architect on a contract
basis but I needed some stability which
I got with the job I just started with
Infosys as a cyber security consultant
happened after I took the course first
and foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching stay tuned for more from Simply
learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you